welcome everyone um
back to um theory of computation
so
we are now at lecture number 15 and
if this is an important
lecture um well all of our lectures are
important but
this is i'm going to introduce
one of the major topics
that we're going to see
going on in various forms through the
rest of the semester which is the notion
of a complete problem in this case it's
going to be an np complete problem
and
i think some of you have probably heard
of that concept already maybe you've
seen it in some courses or other but
we're going to do that in a
in a rather careful and formal way
over the next couple of lectures
so we are following up on our
previous discussions about complexity
time complexity
we defined
the time and non-deterministic time
complexity classes as you may remember
the classes p and np
talked about the p versus np problem
looked at some interesting algorithm for
showing problems in p called dynamic
programming
and we started to move toward our
discussion of np completeness with the
introduction of polynomial time
reducibility
which is
related to some of the earlier
reducibility notions that we discussed
in the computability section
so
let's
[Music]
quick review um
what it means for one problem to be
polynomial time reducible to another
this follows our pattern of
reducibility concepts where
um if a problem is reducible to another
problem and that other problem is
solvable then the first problem is
solvable so if a problem is reducible to
an easy problem that problem becomes
easy too
um and
the kind of reduction that we're going
to be looking at here are the mapping
reductions but now where the reductions
are computable in polynomial time
and so we had this um
result we mentioned last time that if a
is polynomial time reducible to b and b
is in p then a is also in p
um
[Music]
so that's going to be um
critically important for the
you know for the
for the whole um
of discussion that's coming
um
our intuition about pnnp um
repeating that here um the np problems
are the ones where you can verify
membership easily
as opposed to
being able to test membership easily
those are the problems that are in p the
verification typically requires
some kind of a
certificate
that establishes kind of a proof
that the input is a member of that
language
um
and the
big question of the field which remains
an unsolved problem
is whether p equals np it's called the p
versus np question
and we don't know the answer so whether
there are problems that are
in np um solvable and nondeterministic
polynomial time typically these are
problems that involve searching whether
they can be solved in polynomial time
typically without the searching um
and
uh if p
were equal to np then you could always
eliminate searching and a p were
different from np then there were cases
where you need to search um and we don't
know the answer to that uh
so
in
the direction of exploring uh this
this question and its ramifications
we introduced this problem called sat
these are the boolean formulas
which have an assignment
that
enable that event makes them evaluate to
true
um
so we call those satisfiable formulas
and uh we um mentioned but have not yet
proven and we will not prove until the
next lecture on tuesday
that there is this theorem
uh kind of a very remarkable theorem
that says that if you have uh you take
the satisfiability problem and if it is
solvable quickly then all of the np
problems are solvable quickly so if sat
is in p then p equals np so in a sense
sat is kind of you know the
uh
it's sort of the super
np problem in the sense that all of the
difficulty of any np problem is
is embedded within sat so if sat becomes
easy then all of the other np problems
become easy um and we'll eventually
prove that but right now we're kind of
setting up
the um terminology to allow us to do
that
um
so uh anyway we'll we'll we'll get there
um
so
the the the key ingredient for proving
this kook 11 theorem is polynomial time
reducibility
what we're going to show
is that every problem in np
can be polynomial time reduced to set
so every np problem can be converted
into a set problem
and so
working toward that because when you
think about it you know there are
infinitely many problems in np and
um
being able to show that all of them
are reducible to sat as in a sense kind
of um you have to prove a kind of a
higher level theorem it's not just a
single reduction we're kind of
exhibiting a schema of reductions which
shows that all of these problems can be
reduced to set
um and kind of
developing
our
um
you know our intuition toward that
direction we're going to look at some
specific polynomial time reductions
today um
and
we'll start out with a reduction between
two problems we have not yet seen one of
them called threesat and the other one
called clique so on this slide we're
going to introduce those two problems
so remembering again about boolean
formulas
we're going to consider a special
class
of boolean formulas a restricted form of
boolean form formulas called conjunctive
normal form
and so this formula here in particular
is in that conjunctive normal form
um so just remember um i was explaining
some of this to someone else uh
earlier this morning showing some of
these slides and it was pointed out that
not all of you may have be familiar with
these um the boolean operations of and
and or
uh so this is the or symbol here
this is the and symbol here
you know they operate you know hopefully
you've seen the just the concept of
boolean and or
or is in a sense a little bit like a
union um and it's like an intersection
and the the symbols here are kind of a
little bit similar to the union and
intersections you know the intersection
the union intersection symbols
themselves like or the v-shaped is a
little bit like a
pointy union symbol and the in the um
upside-down v-shape is a little like a
pointy intersection symbol so maybe
that's if you haven't seen those seen
that connection before maybe it's
interesting to observe that
but anyway um
what makes this
uh formula be in conjunctive normal form
well the conjunctive normal form
formulas
are organized in a certain way they have
um
these groups called clauses within the
parentheses
that are added together that are
connected by these and
and operations um
and
within those groups which are called
clauses
the um
elements are
ored together
those elements
are going to be either variables
or
variables with negation negated
variables um
so uh just to repeat that
uh these well i'll just just state those
those variables or negated variables are
going to be called literals um
and
the
ors of a bunch of literals are going to
be called clauses
okay this is just the standard
terminology in the field
okay so
um a literal is a variable or a negated
variable
and a clause is an or
of literals
okay just a definition
all right so we have a bunch of these
clauses here each of the clauses has an
or of of liter of literals in it
now
a chomsky
conjunctive normal form
uh formula i guess they're both c and
f's but uh
it's conjunctive normal form formula is
one that's written as an and of these
clauses
okay so we take these clauses which
themselves are ors we and them together
we get a formula that's conjunctive
normal form conjunctive stands for and i
think uh conjunction is an and um
and then a three
cnf
is a cnf where each clause has exactly
three literals
so for example this particular
formula is a cnf but it's not a three
cnf because it has at least two clauses
which violate the condition of three
literals per clause this one is okay
obviously
this first clause
and the three sat problem
so this is the first of the two problems
we're going to be talking about
the three sad problem
is
the satisfiability problem restricted to
these three cnf formulas
so this is the collection of
setup of three cnf formulas which are
satisfiable
so you can think of it as a kind of a
special case
of the sat problem where we only care
about formulas of the special kind
um
this being a special case you might
imagine that this might be an easier
problem to solve but in general it turns
out not to be as we will see this is
just as solving this special case is
just as har as hard as solving the
general case for satisfiability
um
now let's turn to the second
of these two languages up in the
headline
uh
the clique problem
um
so for that we gonna turn to graph
theory
so we're going to consider graphs
you know
points and lines connecting them
and we will say that a clique
in a graph
is a collection of nodes collection of
the points that are all pairwise
connected by lines
and a k click is one where you have case
arch nodes
so
here we have a three click four click
and five click
um and the clique problem
is to try to find cliques of a certain
specified size
embedded within a given graph
so you'd like to know whether you're
going to be given a graph and it targets
click-sized k
and you want to know is there a subset
of the nodes in the graph
of size k
that are all connected to one another
that's the cleat problem
um
so obviously
um
the clique problem just as with the
satisfiability problem is a decidable
problem you can just try every possible
subset of k nodes
and see whether it constitutes a clique
but that's in general going to be an
exponential algorithm if you have you
know
you know k is a large value like it
might be half the size of the graph you
might be looking for a very large clique
then you have to try
many many subsets in order to see
whether uh any one of them is a clique
it's also going to be and i hope you get
this intuition this is a problem that's
in np
the cleat problem is an np problem
because you can easily verify
that a graph uh has a k click just by
exhibiting the click
okay um
now uh
uh
so the clique language here is you're
given a graph and a k and you want to
know does the graph contain a cake
league um and what we're going to show
is that these two problems are connected
that the three set problem and the cleat
problem are related in that you can
reduce in polynomial time three sat to
click
okay so this is um
you know
at
you know just standing back at it
back for a minute you know that seems
kind of surprising there's no real
reason
you know uh obviously anyway no obvious
reason why there should be a connection
between three sat and click click they
look very different from one another
but we do give that uh we will give that
reduction
and um it then that implies that if you
can find a way of solving the clique
problem quickly that'll give you a way
of solving the the three set problem
quickly
um and that's going to be the whole
point of this um
so we're going to show this over the
next
slide or two um this this polynomial
time reduction and this is something i'm
going to walk through it slowly
but this is one where you it's really
important to try to get a sense of how
it's working um
uh because this is the kind of thing
that we're going to be doing a lot of
and you're going to be asked to do it
also on the homework and and possibly on
the final exam i hate to use that as the
motivating force here but at least it
might be one motivation for some of you
that you have to understand how to do uh
this kind of a reduction
okay so
you know i i think at a high level
what's going on is we're showing how to
recode
a
boolean formula satisfiability problem
into the problem of testing whether a
graph has a clique
um
so
let's see if we have any questions here
that are coming up in the in the chat um
okay so i this is an interesting
question here can we always convert
a boolean
formula
into conjunctive into conjunctive normal
form
first of all yes the answer is you can
always convert a boolean formula into an
equivalent one in ins into in cnf
but
in general that might make the formula
exponentially larger
[Music]
so
just the mere fact that you can convert
formulas into into conjunctive normal
form doesn't mean
that solving um
that you know that solving uh
um
conjunctive normal form uh formulas for
testing satisfiability of the of the cnf
formulas is going to be as hard as
testing the general case because just
the conversion might be exponential um
there's something more uh more
a little bit more complicated going on
um
than that
so let's uh
um
let me just see here
uh if he is a satisfiable formula which
is not in cnf can be
so a similar
um you know similar question so the
questions that i'm getting are about
converting formulas uh to cnf um
so yeah you can do it but not in
polynomial time in general because the
resulting formula you get might be much
larger
um if you if you're looking for an
equivalent formula if you're not looking
for an equivalent formula then you know
of course then depending upon what
you're looking for you might be able to
find something smaller
um
ah
this is a this is a i guess a good basic
question
why is clique in np
um
because isn't doesn't verifying that you
have a clique require going through all
the possible cliques
once i
you have to understand what verifying
means verifying means you can verify
something if you're given a certificate
in the case of a clique
the click problem the certificate is the
clique
um so once you have the certificate you
can do the verification in polynomial
time finding the certificate of course
might be difficult
so you only think of np in the context
of having that certificate
so in a case for like
compositeness the certificate might be
the factor
um
you know
anyway i hope that's you know it's there
there are problems sometimes with what
the certificate is is not necessarily
obvious um but there can be a
certificate um for
um showing that the
that the input is in the language but in
the ones that we've done so far maybe
you can argue that this certificate is
sort of an obvious thing but it's not
always an obvious thing
um
okay
why don't we move on then
um
so let's see how do we do
this polynomial time reduction from
three sat to click
okay
here we go
um
so i'm just going to give a reduction
that's that's that's what the definition
means i'm going to give a way of
converting
formulas
to
pairs
a g and a k
where the formula is going to be solid
satisfiable if and only if the graph has
a k click
okay so let's kind of a little bit do it
by example
and
in order to do that
so here's going to be a formula now it's
in three cnf that's what i need you know
in order to be doing this reduction i'm
converting three cnf formulas into
clique problems
we have to a little bit understand what
it means
when we say
uh we talk about the satisfiability of a
formula like this because it's going to
be helpful in doing the reduction you
know obviously it's satisfiable means
that the form you can find an assignment
of the variables so you're going to set
each of these variables a b and c and so
on to true or false
and you want to make the whole formula
evaluate to true but what does that
actually mean
[Music]
it means that because of the structure
of the formula
that making this formula true
corresponds to making each clause true
because
the clauses are all added together so
the only way for the formula to be true
is to make each clause true
and to make a clause true
you have to make at least one of the
literals true
so it's another way of thinking about
uh satisfying this formula
you need satisfying these and a
satisfying assignment
makes at least one true literal in every
clause
it's really important to think about it
that way
because that's what's going to be um
[Music]
kind of the basis
for doing
this reduction and all of the reductions
it's kind of what makes three set easy
to think about in terms of its
satisfiability
if you had a sort of a general um
satisfiability problem and you had a
satisfiable formula there's no sort of
obvious way of sort of seeing what the
satisfying assignment looks like but
here we understand what it looks like it
has that very special form
making one true literal in every clause
at least one true literal in every
clause
okay so now we're going to do the
reduction so i'm going to take from this
formula you and
you have to understand you know i know
for some of you you know you're going to
be you know chafing why am i going so
slowly but i want to make sure that
we're all together in understanding what
the rules of the game are and what we're
trying to do
um
we're trying to convert
this formula into a graph and a number
so right now my job is to do this
reduction is to exhibit that graph
okay so i'm going to do that in kind of
two steps i'll first i'm going to tell
you what the nodes of the graph are
then then i'll tell you what the edges
of that graph
finally i'll tell you what the number k
is
that's the way this polynomial time
reduction is going to work
and we have to also
observe at the very end
that the reduction that i'm given giving
you this
procedure for building this graph can be
done in polynomial time but that i think
you'll see once i'm done that that's
pretty obvious
okay so first as i promised the nodes um
so the nodes of this graph are going to
correspond to the literals of the
formula every literal is going to become
a node in the graph and it's going to be
labeled
with
the um name of that literal so it's
every node is going to be labeled an a
or b or or c bar
and so on so here it goes
okay so those are the nodes
of the graph g
one for each literal in the formula
okay
labeled as promised
now i have to tell you what the edges
look like
the edges are going to be
um i'm going to tell you what the edges
are by first telling you what they are
not
i'm going to first explain to you what
the forbidden edges are
what what edges i'm going to
promise not to include
and then the ones that i
will include are going to be all the
others
okay so what are going to be the
forbidden edges first of all um
the the forbidden
edges are going to be of two types one
is the edges between nodes
that come from
literals in the same clause so i would
just call that
no edges within a clause
okay so for example these three nodes
will not be connected to one another and
i'm going to indicate that by writing
red dashed lines which means there's not
an edge there
okay those are those are forbidden from
having an edge
okay so these three have no edge and the
same thing for every other uh triple of
three nodes that come from uh clauses
okay those are
no edges there
and there's one other category of edge
that i'm forbidding
and that are edges that can
that um go between
inconsistent labels and the nodes with
inconsistent labels so for example
between a and a bar those are
inconsistent
you know nothing's wrong with a going a
to d those are not inconsistent those
are just different labels or going from
a to a that's okay
but from a to a bar that's that's not
allowed um so that's going to be another
forbidden edge
or for example a to a bar here
for b a bar to a or for example from
this c bar to c
forbidden
okay so imagine you're going to write
down all of those forbidden edges and
then once you've done that
uh
those are all of the the forbidden edges
and then after
[Music]
taking those away
you're going to be putting in all the
other edges possible
so for example as a let me just uh
gray those out so they don't interfere
with the picture
b from a to a to d
um there's going to be an edge um
because those are not forbid you know a
to a not forbidden because
they they're in different
um
they are in different uh
clauses and they're not inconsistent
they're they're consistent with one
another so here are a whole bunch of
other i'm not showing them all becomes
very messy but uh here are all the other
edges between nodes uh which are
where there isn't there's
no pro
within they're not forbidden
okay and that's
that's the graph
that's g
g is all
those nodes and those edges um which are
not forbidden
now i just have to tell you what k a is
k is going to be the number of clauses
that's going to be the size of the
clique i'm looking for in this graph g
that i just spelled out for you
and i'm going to claim
that
this graph here that i just described
will have a k clique
k is the number of clauses
exactly when
fee was satisfiable
it's kind of kind of cool you know um if
he is satisfiable then there will be a
cake leak here
and if he was not satisfiable okay clean
so we have to we're gonna prove that as
a claim on the next slide
okay so k is the number of clauses
all right
um
any questions on that on that
construction so i've done with the
construction what's left is to argue why
the construction works
so far so good let's move on
okay
um
so um
so here is that very same construction i
eliminated the red uh
forbidden edges these are the ones that
were remaining
plus you know anything else that was not
forbidden
that was the same formula that i had
from the previous slide
now i'm going to claim that that formula
is satisfiable exactly when g has a k
click now why in the world is that
so this is an if and only if it's proved
in both directions
and this is going to be the typical kind
of thing that you're going to want to do
when you're exhibiting a
uh
you know one of these reductions
which is you're going to have an
opportunity to do that um and we'll do
do that too
in our examples
uh
okay
so now
uh what i'm what i want to show
is that
uh
if fee is satisfiable so let's prove the
forward direction if p is satisfiable
then g has a k click
okay so first of all if fee is
satisfiable that means it has a
satisfying assignment
okay
now here's a common confusion i'm not
sure whether it's helpful to
sprinkle the confusions in along with
the discussion but
in case you're worried
you might ask well how do i find that
satisfying assignment i thought that was
you know
exponential
exponentially hard to do
this is a proof this is not an algorithm
okay we're just trying to argue the con
correctness of this construction
so there's no longer any concern about
how to find an assignment i'm just
saying if there isn't a sign if there is
a satisfying assignment then something
will happen something that then then um
something will happen in particular then
we will show that g has a cake league
so
let's say
fee is satisfiable
so it has some assignment let's take
that satisfying assignment
and remember
that in any satisfying assignment
uh to a formula in cnf
that makes at least one literal true in
every clause
so
let's just pick one of those there might
be several clauses which have multiple
true literals in that case just pick one
of them
arbitrarily
okay so i don't know what the i don't
have this sort of indicated on this
diagram here but imagine you know maybe
in the very first clause a was true in
the second clause b was true in the
third clause
e compliment ebar was true and you know
not not
you know
e bar was true which means e itself was
false but e bar was true and that's the
way each of those clauses in turn uh got
to be true you know in this particular
satisfying assignment
because you're going to pick one true
literal in every clause and now
from
that choice
of literals one per clause
i'm going to look at the corresponding
nodes in g
and i'm going to claim
that those nodes taken together
form a k click
okay so first of all
do they have the right number of nodes
well sure because
i'm picking one node per click i already
said k is the number of cliques so i'm
getting exactly ka nodes so i have at
least the right number
of nodes but how do i know they're all
connected to one another those nodes uh
that i just picked
well they're all connected to each other
because i'm going to say well because
there were no forbidden edges among them
and remember that we put in all possible
edges except for the forbidden ones
so how do i know there are no forbidden
edges
well what were the rules for being
forbidden means they two nodes in the
same clique in the same clause
well i'm picking one node per clause
so i can never be having two nodes from
the same clause so i'm never going to
run into trouble with uh the first
condition of being forbidden so what's
the second possibility for being
forbidden is that i'm picking two nodes
which are inconsistent
well how do i know that i didn't end up
with two nodes with inconsistent labels
that would be bad because then they
would have a forbidden edge and what my
result would not be a clique
how do i know i didn't end up picking
um
uh
in this group i pick a and in this group
i pick a a bar
well because they all came from the same
assignment
those are all of the true letters they
were all true literals
in clauses it's not possible that a was
true in this clause and a bar is true in
that clause because if a is true here a
bar has got to be false it can't be the
true literal in this clause
so i cannot have any inconsistent any
inconsistent nodes
appearing
among the nodes of my clique
and so they're not in the same clause
they're not inconsistent so the edge has
to be there and that's going to be true
for every pair of nodes in that clique
in that in that group of nodes and
that's why it's a click
um
so that proves one direction now we stop
to prove the other direction because we
have to say well if g has a k clique how
do we know that ph is satisfied so
that's the reverse
so let's just take any k clique that's
in g
and how do i know i can get from that a
satisfying assignment to the formula
um
uh
good um
getting some good questions here in the
chat but let me just move on
um take any uh so
proving the reverse
this the reverse direction but we're
assuming we have a cake leak to take any
such k-click
now first of all you observe that it's
got to have
one node in every clause
it can't have two nodes in the same
clause or zero nodes in in a clause
first of all it can't have two nodes in
the same clause why well because those
nodes are never connected to one another
so that they cannot be both in the same
clique because all the nodes in a clique
are connected to one another
um by construction by the way we
construct a g
nodes from the same clause are not
connected so they cannot appear in a
clique together
so um
there's going to be at most one node
from every clause appearing in this
clique but and but but
appearing in in this clip but we also
have we know we have k notes
so that means if there is at most one
per um per clause
and we only have k clauses that means
every clause has got to have one
you know if some clause is missing or
note then there's going to be some other
clause that has two
so we know that every um
that this clique that would that g
has has exactly one node in every clause
so how do we get from that a satisfying
assignment
so what we're going to do is
take the current
corresponding literals
that correspond to that one node in the
that was in the uh clique
take those literals and set those
literals to be true
which means setting the variable to be
true
um or setting um you know
if the literal was a bar then setting a
to be false because you want a bar to be
true you want to set the literals to be
true
well now we're setting um there's one
note in each clause we're setting one
literal uh the corresponding literal
true so that's going to set one true
literal in every clause
so that means it's going to be
satisfying there's one thing that one
has to really to be
careful here to double check to make
sure that we're doing this consistently
that we're not being asked to set you
know a
true and also a bar true because then
that would not be
possible
but a and a bar are not connected
so it's we're never going to be trying
to set both a and a bar true if so we're
going to be trying to set a true we're
never going to try to set a bar true
because those are not those a and a bar
cannot be in the same clique they're not
connected to each other
okay so
that
is the argument um and lastly
i claim we're not going to look at this
in detail that it's kind of obvious that
this reduction can be done in polynomial
time namely if i give you that formula
you can write out that graph in
pretty easily
there's no hard work to be done in
writing out that that graph or counting
up the number of clauses
so that's that's the proof
that i can reduce three statically
um
and it tells you also that if i could
solve click quickly
then i can stop threesat quickly
and this is the whole point
because i can convert now clique
problems to three sat problems
no
no i couldn't i'm sorry i got backwards
convert three set problems the clique
problem so if i can solve quick click
easily then i can solve three set easily
right i just showed a way of converting
these formulas to graphs so if that's so
that says if i can solve the graphs
easily then i can solve the formulas
okay
why don't we uh turn to some oh question
checking but you know we can also
um why don't i i'll launch a check-in
but we'll
we
let's just see
i'm seeing many many questions here
which are actually what my check-in is
about
i'll turn it back to you guys uh
okay so
where did we use the fact
um that we have
three
uh literals per clause what does this
thing just work even if we had any
number of literals per clause
um
what do you think
we're having a
we've got a tight race here
hmm uh
truth is losing out unfortunately
all right oh it's really close but still
okay
uh
one more okay it's neck and neck
okay almost done
10
seconds
are we done here okay that's it
uh ending polling
uh
yes
truth is
thank god
um
yeah it works for any size clause we
didn't use the fact that it's a three c
and f it could have been any number here
uh
so it's well we've got a i guess it's a
plural plurality here though that not a
majority um
no we didn't where did we use three in
any of these argument i didn't mention
it maybe you were imagining that that is
going to be part of it but three does
not come into this at this discussion at
all if you think about how it's why it's
working
um even if we had you know one of these
clauses had 10 literals in it
as long as k is the number of clauses
and we don't connect
any variables any literals internal to a
clause
this whole argument is going to still
work so please check that make sure you
understand what's going on because i can
see that a good chunk of you
have not got this right
um
uh so i got a good question here uh what
if it's only just one big clause so it's
like the whole formula is just one big
war so what does happen in that case
good question so in that case um
uh
so the you know suppose has one big
clause with a hundred literals
that's the whole formula it's just a big
war so we know the formula is going to
be satisfiable by the way obviously um
so if you look at the corresponding g
it's going to have 100 nodes because
there's one for every literal um
none of them are going to be connected
to each other because they're all in the
same clause
um so it looks like we're going to be in
tough shape trying to find a clique
there because there's no edges at all
everything's forbidden but what is k
k is going to be 1 in that case because
there's only one clause
and
uh
kind of a degenerate case but a clique
with just one
you know just a single node
is it counts as a one clique
because it's just one node there's no
need for any edges at all it still
counts as a clique so it'll still it'll
still work out um
uh let's see what else here uh that was
kind of a fun question that you asked me
thank you um
uh there are a lot of questions um
i think we're actually pretty near the
break also we'll just see
yeah um
so why don't i um
oh
many many questions here uh
so i i think i'm gonna start start the
clock going down for our um our coffee
break and um
and i will take some of these questions
i'll try to answer some of these
questions oops
um try to answer some of these questions
um
afterward
uh all right
good
all right
um
so i got a question about
making sure why nodes don't have
inconsistent labels if i understand the
question correctly
um so these would be nodes
um
so i never put edges between nodes with
inconsistent labels that's the rule
that's my construction i get to i get to
say how the construction works so those
two nodes with inconsistent labels can
never be in the same clique
because
there's no edge between them
so i'm not sure that answered the
question there but that was uh
um
let's see
so getting another question here
since any boolean formula can be
converted to cnf
does that mean um is sat polynomial time
reducible to clique as well
monomial time reducible to clique but
not for the reason that any boolean
formula can be converted to c and f
because
that conversion
um
is going to be an exponential conversion
in general the conversion to c and f so
you have to be careful about what we
mean by converting a formula to cnf
um
uh so also getting questions what
happens in the case of one set well we
didn't really talk about one set
uh suppose or i guess so the question is
suppose there's only a single
literal per clause
that's an interesting another
sort of edge case here what happens
under those circumstances
so um there's only a single literal per
clause um
uh so you have to work out what happens
but in that case
um
uh
all the clauses just have one literal in
them
and now they have um
uh
um
the only way
uh
this
if you think about what is a when you
have a
one cnf so there's only um
one
literal per clause the only way that can
be satisfiable is you have to make each
literal true because there's no warring
anymore so every literal has to be true
in the assignment so that means you can
never have inconsistent literals um and
that's the only case when you would not
have an edge because you're not the
forbidden is the forbidden condition
won't happen because you don't have more
than one uh node per per clause every
clause is going to have just a single
node in it uh so
it really comes down to whether or not
you have an inconsistently labeled um
inconsistent clauses
i i didn't explain that super well but
it's the
the argument still works there you
should check it for yourself
um
so this is a basic question how do we
see that f is polynomial time
i i'm not sure i want to expend a lot of
you know a lot of discussion on that
because
the the conversion from the formula
to the graph
is kind of a one-to-one
you know every no every uh literal
becomes a node
um the rule for when edges are present
it's a very simple rule so i guess i
would argue
i'm not sure what what more to say it
seems pretty clear that the
conversion that reduction is polynomial
time computable i mean if you wrote a
program to do that it would operate very
quickly
um
is it possible for g to have a k plus n
clique where n is greater than zero and
does that matter
now if you think about it
the biggest possible clique that this
graph g could have is k
it could never have more than
uh uh you know a bigger clique because
two nodes in the same uh clause are
never connected
you only have k clauses
so the answer is no you cannot have a
bigger
a bigger than a k click it's just not
going to happen
does each clause need to have the same
number of literals i don't see why
um
uh
so question is why are we worrying about
threesat um
since it didn't seem to matter here
there are other examples where it does
matter i i i'm actually not sure if
we'll see one or not but um there there
are cases where it does matter
um let me just see if there's any quick
questions here
uh
somebody's saying doesn't does
do we have to worry about there being a
polynomial number of literals
so you have to think about what you what
that question means the size of the
input which includes all of the literals
is n
so there's going to be at most n
literals
um because that's the size of the input
uh the i mean
at most uh and literals appearing so
you don't have to worry about that being
polynomial because by the way we're
we're defining the size of the input is
going to be at most n literals
i hope that's clear
uh
okay
when we talk about power
okay so this is a good question when we
talk about polynomial time
it's polynomial in the representation of
of the input which is if you want to
think about it in terms of bits that's
fine or whatever it's not going to
matter if you use some larger alphabet
but the number of symbols you need you
know in your fixed size alphabet the
number of symbols you need to write down
that input in whatever your reasonable
encoding is is going to be n and it's
going to be polynomial in n polynomial
in that
length of the input
um
so another question is does sat reduce
the three set yes we that we will see um
sat actually does polynomial time reduce
the three set not by converting to an
equivalent formula but by some more uh
somewhat more involved argument uh than
that okay why don't we move on some of
these are going to come out anyway in
the lecture
okay so now let's talk about mp
completeness because we've kind of set
things up we're not going to prove that
you know the basic theorem the cook 11
theorem about mp completeness but at
least we'll be able to make the
definition
okay here's our definition you know what
it means for a problem to be in be
complete
um
uh
so a language
b is called np complete
if it has two properties
number one is that has to be a member of
np
and number two
every language in np has the polynomial
time reduced to that
to that language to that np complete
language in order for it to be np
complete
okay so
simple picture
has to be in nnp
and everything in np reduces to it
um
and so that's kind of the magical
property that we claimed that that sat
has sat for for one thing is obviously
in np
and
as we
the cook 11 theorem shows
or will show
everything in npe is reducible to sat so
that's going to be our first example of
an np complete problem
um
uh so now
uh and we're going to get what we
claimed also for sat that if sat or any
other np-complete problem
turns out to be solvable in polynomial
time
then every np problem is solvable in
polynomial time and and that's immediate
because everything is reducible in
polynomial time to the np complete
problem
so if you can do it easily you can do
everything easily just by going through
the reduction
okay
so the quick level theorem as i
mentioned is that sad is np-complete
and we're going to actually prove it
next lecture but let's assume for the
remainder of this lecture that we know
it to be true because so i'll use the
terminology of problems being np
complete uh assuming that we know um
that we have uh sat as empty complete
okay
so we're gonna we're gonna be
using some of the things that were
proving next lecture uh just
in the terminology that we're going to
be talking today
okay so here's the picture
here's the class np
and everything in np
is
polynomial time reducible to set
sat itself is a member of np but i
didn't want to show it that way because
it makes the picture kind of hard to uh
hard to uh
hard to display
so
just from the perspective of the
reduction everything in np is polynomial
time reducible to sad we'll show that
next lecture
another thing that we'll show next
lecture
is that sat in turn is polynomial time
reducible to three sat so
three stat as you remember are just
those problems that are in conjunction
three
are in three c and f
um
and then
what we showed today is that three set
is polynomial time reducible to clique
so now
taking the assumption that sat is np
complete
so everything is polynomial time
reducible to sat which is in turn
polynomial time reducible to three sat
in in turn reducible to click
these reductions as we've seen before
composed
um
you can just reply apply one reduction
function after the next
if each one each one individually is
polynomial the whole thing as a
combination is going to be polynomial so
now we know that three sat is going to
be also np complete because
we can reduce anything in np to stat and
then to three set and then we get a
reduction directly to three sat by
composing those two reductions and then
furthermore at the clique so now we
uh have several np complete problems and
moving beyond that
we have the hand path problem which we
are going to talk about next and we'll
show another
reduction um
in addition to the one we just showed to
click now one going from three set to
hand
um
okay uh so in general
i think the the the the take away
message is that to show some language as
np complete you want to show that three
sat is polynomial time reducible to it
um
uh
okay
some good questions coming in i'll try
to answer those so you're going to
retake
3sat and reduced to c that's the sort of
the most typical case
or you might have there's going to be
other examples too we might start with
another problem that you've already
shown to be np complete and read and
reduce it to your language so it doesn't
have to start with reset
though
often it does
um
okay why do we why is this concept
important
so i would say there are two reasons um
and this is going to get a little bit at
the uh some of the chat questions um
first of all
if you're faced with some copy new
computational problem you've got some
robotics problem
um that you want to solve in your thesis
and you need to some algorithm about
whether the robot arm can do such and
move in a certain such a way and involve
searching you know possibly searching
through a space of different kinds of
motions and you want to know you know i
need a either i'd like to have a i like
to find a polynomial algorithm to solve
that problem
i'm using this as an example because
this actually did happen to one of the
former students from this class who was
working in robotics and they actually
end up proving that the problem that
they were trying to solve is np complete
um
so
um
uh
that's useful information because even
though knowing a problem is np complete
doesn't guarantee that it's not in p
because conceivably p equals np
what it does tell you that if you show
if you have a problem that's np complete
and it does turn out to be in p
then all then p equals np so the tremend
would be tremendous surprising
consequences
of
of your problem if it was known to be
np-complete ending up in p so generally
people take a proof of np completeness
as powerful evidence that the problem is
not in p even though it's not quite a
proof
it's powerful evidence that it's not in
p and so you might as well give up
working on trying to find a polynomial
algorithm for it because if you do
you know you don't have to worry about
robotics anymore you're going to you
know become famous as a complexity
theory person um
so i wouldn't worry about so if you show
problems np complete you can pretty much
assume it's almost certainly not in p um
now there's another reason related to
the to the for the theorists uh to be
care about mp completeness and that is
if you're trying to prove p is different
from np or p equals np as one of the
chat questions is raising um
you know the problem you know
in order to prove p different from np
you know the most likely approach is you
pick some p problem in np and show it's
not in p
right that's what it would mean for them
to be different you're going to pick
some np problem and show it's not not a
p problem
well
um
one thing would be terrible
is possibly p is different from np and
you pick the wrong problem
like suppose i'd spent all my time
trying to show
you know back
20 years ago i'm working really hard
trying to show composites
is not in pain
which is would have been perfectly
reasonable to do
because composites is an np and was not
known to be in p 20 years ago
um and then i invested tons of effort to
try to prove because you know i like
number theory or god knows what to prove
that composites is not in p
and then it turns out composites wasn't
in p it was the wrong problem to pick
even though p might be different from np
but what np completeness guarantees is
that if you work on a problem which is
np-complete you could you can't pick the
wrong problem because if any problem is
in np and not in p an np complete
problem is going to be an example of
that
right because if the np complete problem
is in p everything in np is in p
so if np is different from p you know
the complete problems are not in p so
you might as well work on one of those
so those are two
ways in which np completeness and has
turned out to be is an important concept
okay so here's a check-in um
uh
again this
you guys are kind of getting maybe
you're getting
started to think the way i think you get
is some at least one of you would ask
this question in the chat
um
which language that we've probably seen
is most analogous to sat
okay atm etm
or zero to the k1 to the k
uh
obviously this is maybe subjective you
may have your own interpretation of what
that means
this in a sense perhaps no right answer
but what do you think
uh
okay that's it
um i don't know i don't know how in the
world that you could see this problem is
analogous to to zero to the k1 to the k
but okay um
i'm sure you have your reason
um
yes this is a lot like eight
atm why
well because for one thing we showed in
a homework problem
that all
um touring recognizable languages are
reducible to atm mapping reducible to
atm so that's a little bit like the
notion of completeness
that we have for satisfiability
um because all np problems are going to
be reducible to sad
um
and the other thing too is that once we
start once we
uh we started we want to show other
problems are undecidable we reduced atm
to them and that's also very similar
we're going to be reducing sat or
threesat
so it's indirectly from sat to other
problems in order to show that they're
np complete so that they're hard they're
they're that they're hard in a sense
and so uh in kind of both those ways
atm and sat are kind of playing similar
roles one key difference however
between atm and sat is in the for atm we
can prove
that it's undecidable
but for sat we don't know how to prove
it's outside of p
that would those would be the analogous
situations
um
and
uh so
the the story for sat which is kind of
easily solved by a diagonalization
argument for atm
there's reasons to believe that we will
see later that diagonalization is not
going to work to prove sat
outside of p
and
besides that we don't really have any
good methods
um
so
uh anyway
uh let's move on
why is etm less analogous
uh
i know because atm was the first problem
we showed undecidable and sad is kind of
the first problem that we're going to be
showing np complete
i guess that would be my answer
um
okay let's continue so let's show now
that
handpath is np-complete assuming that we
know sat
or threesat is np complete
okay so we're going to give a reduction
from 3sat to handpath that that
that that's what that's what this is
about it's just like what we did for
clique but now for him path um
and and this is going to be very typical
in in these reductions typically what
happens
is that you're trying to simulate
a formula
use you know a boolean formula for
satisfiability
from the satisfiability perspective
you're trying to simulate that formula
with some sort of structures
inside the target language which would
be hand path
and so what the lingo that
people use is that you're going to build
gadgets to simulate the structures in
the formula namely
the variables the literals and the and
the clauses
okay these are going to be substructures
of
the um
either you know the graph in this case
that you're that you're building um
we'll see what that means so let's take
a formula here
and
uh let's again try to imagine how we
would reduce that
to the hand path problem so the
reduction would produce
a graph no it would produce a hand path
instance so a g s and t want to know is
there a hamiltonian path from s to t in
the graph
and this is going to be not the whole
graph but this is going to be a
substructure in that graph the next
slide is going to have the global
structure of the graph graph
but here this is going to be a key
element and it's we're going to call
that
the variable gadget
okay what does it look like i don't know
if you can see it on your um
clearly enough but these
uh
edges so there are four outside notes
here the edges connecting them are all
kind of pointed downward
and then there are these horizontal
nodes here
and there are edges connecting them both
left to right and right to left
okay there's a row of these horizontal
nodes okay so you get the picture of
what this looks like
um
you have to look carefully to see the
arrowheads i
maybe should have made those a little
bigger
okay so now um
uh
whoops
let me let me just see so now if we're
trying to get from this node to that
node imagine now you're trying to build
a hamiltonian path
because this is going to be a part
of that graph g
that i'm constructing
now remember for them there to be a
hamiltonian graph
that means you have to go through every
node
in the graph so if i want to get from s
to t
the only way i'm going to be able to to
go to hit these
horizontal nodes here
is
um
by picking them up
uh
as i go from s to t
so the only possibility is if you think
about it is it would be for the
sequence to go like this
if you could if that comes through for
you so the the path would go from s to
this node and then through
these hops of
along these horizontal nodes and then
down to the bottom node here
okay so that's one way
that you can get from here down to there
and pick up all the other nodes along
the way which is they're not going to
have any other possibility possible ways
of getting to them
so i'm going to call that a zigzag
okay but there's another way to get from
s to the bottom node
okay which is going to be by doing sort
of the
dual going to the right then going out
to the left and then down to the bottom
i'm going to call that
a zigzig
okay
and uh with a little kind of little
diagram here just to summarize what it
means
and this is the this is the classic
thing for a variable gadget
because it's a structure
that when you're trying to think about
how the object that you're
asking whether it exists or not the
hamiltonian path how it relates to that
object it's going to have two
possibilities which are going to
correspond to the variable variable
being set true or false in the formula
so we're showing how to
set
you know the simulate the variable
in this hand path instance
so setting the variable is going to
correspond to
to to
to constructing the path
okay
now we also have to make sure not only
that the variable gets set to true or
false but that it gets a set to true and
false in a way that makes this a
satisfying assignment namely that we get
one true literal in every clause
so i'm going to add another gadget here
called a clause gadget
which is just a single node
and visiting that node here
is going to correspond to
um
satisfying that clause to having a true
literal in that clause
um
and now how am i going to get i'm going
to
have it enable
a detour
from these horizontal nodes out to this
clause gadget
so here it is here's that detour
as i'm going from left to right
i can instead of jump doing a single
jump here i could branch out and visit
that clause node
and then come back and pick up my left
to right
uh path as as i was doing before
you realize what i'm trying what's
i hope you're seeing the big picture
because this has to be a hamiltonian
path it has to hit every node that's one
of the requirements so i've got a this
is going to be one of the nodes in my
graph it's the path has got to hit that
node the only way it's going to be able
to hit that node
is by taking a detour off of this
uh horizontal path here
but notice and this is the this is the
key
if i'm doing a zigzag
then i can make the detour and visit
that clause gadget that clause node
but if i'm doing a zag zig
the way this detour is structured does
not allow me
to visit that node
because if i'm going from right to left
here by the time i get to
to this outgoing edge
now i come want to come back
that note has already been taken
it only works if i'm going zag zig from
going from right to left
the left to right if i'm going from left
to right then i can do it for going
right to left no
so this is going to correspond if you
think of left the left to right
direction as true that's going to
correspond to that variable appearing in
the positive way in that clause um but
not in the negative way the negative way
i would reverse
the in and out
of the dot of the detour
flip that around
so now i could only do the detail detour
when i'm going right to left instead of
left to right i hope you get the picture
this is how the structure is working now
what's only left me to do is put it all
together
but
this slide contains the guts um of
what's happening
um so you wanna is is there any question
that i can answer for you
um on this
let's move on to the next slide and then
as questions come up you can be typing
them in we can maybe answer it there
okay so here is the big picture
so imagine we have
that
formula
that we started we're reducing that
formula
um uh
and um
uh
and let's say it has m variables and k
clauses
i'm going to call them clause c1 c2 up
to ck here the m variables appearing
either
positively or
negated in that formula
and this is the way the global structure
of g is going to look like now i'm
getting a question here what do those
horizontal nodes what role do they play
there those nodes are there to allow me
to visit
those
clause
nodes
the the nodes which represent the clause
gadgets which i'm going to place over
here
so imag so here here is that
um here is i mean this is almost a hole
of g that i'm just missing uh some a few
edges but these are all the nodes of g
so remember i'm trying to find out is
there a hamiltonian path from s to t
now if i didn't have to worry about the
these c nodes
the answer would be just yes
in fact there would be many hamiltonian
pairs from s to t because i can do a
zigzag or zx zig through each of these
uh variable gadgets and i would take me
from s to t and i'd be good
it's just these c nodes these nodes
these ci nodes
you know i have to hit them too
so
they're going to be
um
[Music]
visiting them is going to be enabled by
detours from here so
let me just try to show you what that
looks like so i'm going to magnify
little pieces here
uh from from these gadgets here and show
you how these guys are connected up
so here is the x1 gadget
so x1 appears positively in c1
right here's x1 and c1 and so that means
when i'm going left to right i'm going
to be a possibility of visiting c1
um
but now let's look what happens with um
uh
uh
which was the next one i met i i had
here
uh
okay um
so
uh
right
so the next one is oh yeah so that's so
x1 appears positively in c1 and that's
why i have the connection like this uh
now
x1 appears negated in c2
so i only want to do enable the detour
to visit c2 when i'm going right to left
as opposed to left to right
so
this
uh
set of
horizontal nodes is only going to allow
me to take a detour either out to c1
or out to c2 but not to both
because the hamiltonian path is either
going to go left to right or right to
left it can't do both
when it's going through x the x one uh
gadget
okay you need to
didn't kind of you have to i'll try to
help you through it but you have to try
to think about why it's working
so what let's think again together
so x2
also appears in c1
but now it appears negated so i'm going
to have edges from this x2
gadget
whoops
x the x2 gadget
but now look at the look at how i've
i've arranged that detour you know i can
leave on the left leftward side and
return on the rightward side
um which means
i can only
do that detour when i'm going right to
left
okay um
and that's because x2 is negated in c1
okay so there's
maybe it's a lot here if you're if
you're not quite getting it but
the point is let's say try to quickly
prove so that's the whole construction
you just do that for every single
appearance of a literal
in a clause you're going to add these
detours which allow you possibly to go
visit
the uh the clause
um
so the forward direction is
um
why is this true so you take any
satisfying assignment as i suggested
you make the corresponding zigzags or
zag zigs through the variable gadgets
from s to t and then take the detours to
visit the cloud the clause nodes
um
the reverse direction actually is
slightly trickier we're not gonna have
time to go through the subtlety of it
um
but uh
what you want to make sure here
is that you don't have a kind of a a
weird path
um
occurring because i'm going to start
with a hamiltonian path now and build an
assignment
uh and what we want to make sure that
the the path that i'm constructing
doesn't
go from one from this
horizontal nodes
to a
clause node and then back to somebody
else's horizontal nodes um and
is kind of a hodgepodge of things which
don't make any sense in trying to
reconstruct a satisfying assignment what
you what you really want to have happen
is the hamiltonian path should have
clear zigzags and zag zigs that allow
you to decide
how to set the variables
and so that's the role of these little
nodes here these are spacers
that separate the detours from one
another
and that force
um
a visit to the
clause node to come back
to the same
uh place from which it left
otherwise you would never be able to
visit those uh
spacer notes
you have to look in the book for that uh
but
there is a little bit of a detail that
you have to go through you have to show
it must be zig zags and zig zag zigs
and then you get the corresponding truth
assignment and the most satisfied fee uh
for all paths
okay
let's uh again the reduction is
polynomial time computable i'm not going
to say more about that we're kind of a
little bit low on time
um last check in
would this construction still work if g
was undirected
suppose
i just eliminated all the directions
from the from the edges
uh made them lines instead of arrows
would that now show that the undirected
hamiltonian path problem is np-complete
let me see
what do this
okay what do the c nodes represent here
there's one c node for every clause
so there are k clauses
named one c one to ck
and there are k
c nodes these are the so called clause
gadgets
which are going to force
there to be one true literal
um in every clause
for the satisfying assignment
you know it's uh
you know
uh
you have to look at it or or maybe we
can spend a little bit more time
explaining it but uh that's what that's
what the purpose is
um does that mean we need only
does that mean we need only two
inside nodes
uh do we know that so the
the horizontal nodes do we only need two
of them
you won't be able to reuse the reuse
these nodes for multiple detours for one
thing
you know once you've gone to a detour
you come back to the node next over and
so you better not overlay multiple
detours
and
and
also you need to keep them separated
from each other don't forget and this
node x1 can appear in many many
different clauses
um
so
you would need to have um
possibly many
of these horizontal nodes
um
so some now says 2k inside nodes would
suffice
probably 2k i would say 3k just to be
safe for the spacer nodes um you need to
look at carefully at the argument which
is laid out in the textbook um you may
not actually need the spacer nodes but
then it makes the argument just more
more ugly so the way the construction is
done is you have three k
inside notes um that
okay uh again several questions like
that
the graph would start looking messy if
x9 was in c c1
yeah if x9 down here was in c1 yeah i
would
it'd be messy it's okay my c is allowed
uh
all right i think we're let's end the
polling you all are you all in
all right
share results
yes
the answer is no
uh the construction depends on this
being directed i mean you can see that
all over the place but for one thing
uh
you know the whole point of these
detours is the directions of the of the
um edges and so
without that
the the this construction me is is going
to be just a bunch of
you know not going to mean anything it's
not going to prove anything it's
probably always going to be have a have
a hamiltonian path without the
directions um
so i think we're kind of out of time um
uh
a quick review um these are the topics
we've covered i think we're out of time
so i should let you go
um
but i'll stick around for a few minutes
um
in case any of you have any questions
but i need to run off it for myself for
another meeting so i don't have much
that much time
um
clarify my comment about picking the
wrong problem to tackle p versus np
um
when i use composites as an example
you know if i worked hard to prove that
composites is not in p as a way of
proving that there is some np language
which is not in p
um
that would that would have been a
mistake because composites is in p
that would be just i would would have
been working hard to prove something
which we now know was false
so we don't want to spend time
working on the wrong language
um
you know but the nice thing about np
complete languages is that we have a
guarantee
that if p is different from np that that
language is not in p
are there problems that are not in p
that are in np but are not np complete
oh that's a good question
are there
problems in between
uh p and np complete so np complete is
sort of like the hardest problems in np
and the p problems are obviously the
easy problems that are in np and how
about is everything either np complete
or mp
so for one thing there are problems
that are not known to be in either
category
[Music]
uh so we'll discuss some of those in due
course but one of them is like the graph
isomorphism problem testing two graphs
if they're really just permutations of
one another it's clearly a problem in np
but not known to bnp um so there are
problems that are
not known to be either np complete or in
p so there are problems that might be in
between um
but then there's another theorem out
there which says that if you if you
assume that p is different from np then
you can construct
problems which are in between which are
neither np complete nor in p they're np
problems but they're not empty complete
not in p um so
uh those problems themselves are perhaps
somewhat artificial but they at least
prove the point that it is possible to
have these intermediate problems
um
so somebody's asking isn't factorization
one not no you know we
for the case of factorization
um or you have to make sure to make a
language out of that by the way um
uh
but
um
it's a um
uh
stuff because factorization is a
function so we won't really want to be
talking about languages as kind of as
the homework suggests
np and p are classes of languages but
okay that's a separate separate note
there factorization um
is
uh not no
it could factorization could be in p and
it could be np-complete
you know both of those are not ruled out
so uh you know i think most people would
probably venture to guess that it's it's
a problem that's in the in between state
that's neither p nor mp complete but not
known
um
uh do we
who who first thought of this reduction
from three set to hand path it's so
clever
well it wasn't me uh
i believe that uh reduction from
uh
i think that is due to dick carp
who was one of my professors at berkeley
where i was a graduate student he that
was done before i got there it was
around 1971 um when so there were two
famous papers there's the cook paper
there's also the lemon paper that was in
russian that took a while for people to
discover out here in the west but
the cook paper was 1971 and very quickly
followed after he just showed sat as np
complete
but uh after that uh carp
was
he
he had a paper called reducibility among
combinatorial problems and he had a list
of about 20 problems that he showed were
np complete
by reduction from sad um
include clique include handpath and a
bunch of other things um
so
and that's was also a very famous uh
very famous paper um both of those were
people who often talk about cook carp as
sort of together they
uh they they they really sort of
show the importance of np completeness
and exist and no whole notion of np
completeness
um
yeah 21 problems so
yeah so car proof 21 problems wouldn't
be complete in 1972
um so that was shortly after coke showed
that sat was mp complete
um incidentally i think the terminology
np complete wasn't around uh
uh until a little later
and that might have been might be due to
knuth
i'm not sure i remember he did a big
poll
of people about what should be the right
language to use for the for that term
and i think he came up with it
um
all right i'm gonna head off guys nice
uh seeing you all uh so until uh
thursday oh until tuesday uh bye-bye